- Alright everybody, we
have time for one more story
to put a smile on your face, possibly.
This is what I'm liking.
(audience cheers)
The US Gymnastics squad wow'ed
us with their performance
at the Tokyo Olympics this year.
Now they're biggest stars are on the road
for an arena tour like no other.
This is the Gold Over America tour.
(upbeat pop music plays)
(audience cheers)
It's incredible.
It's the coolest idea ever.
We have an Olympic superstars,
Simone Biles and Jordan
Chiles on the line right now.
What's up, y'all?
(audience cheers)
I mean, first of all, congrats
on the Olympics this summer,
but also congrats. I love this whole idea.
This is like a pop concert, rock concert
meets a gymnastics meet.
It looks like that.
Is that what it is?
- Yes. It's very much like a pop show,
gymnastic spectacular. It's
going to be super exciting.
The message throughout the show
has some real and rawness to it.
So I think that's really special.
And we're going to have
the greatest of all greats,
the Olympic team is going to be there.
And we'll also have some from
out of the United States,
which is pretty cool, you know,
having the international side and the US
to come together for this amazing tour.
(audience applauds)
- So what kind of music do you play?
- Yeah, so during the show,
we have a lot of pop hits that
make people want to jump up
and get from the crowd
and kind of dance along.
But whenever we warm up,
we actually warm up to one
of your songs, "Stronger".
- Oh, that's amazing.
(audience cheers)
Wait, I am being told
we have video of this
and I want to see it. So let's see it.
♪ What doesn't kill you
makes you stronger ♪
♪ Stand a little taller ♪
♪ Doesn't mean I'm lonely when I'm alone ♪
♪ What doesn't kill you makes a fighter ♪
♪ Footsteps even lighter ♪
♪ Doesn't mean I'm over 'cause your gone ♪
(audience cheers)
I love that. I want to
come see y'all so badly.
This is the coolest show.
My kids, honestly too,
my kids would love it.
But you Simone, you've become
an advocate for mental health
and even incorporated it into the tour.
So how do you do that?
- Yes, we actually have
one of the segments,
it's called overwhelmed
and it kind of touches on
that anxiety, depression,
whenever you get in that funk,
the closest people around
you kind of lift you up
and support you and
that's how you sometimes
can get out of that.
So I think that is really raw.
Touches on some real life
things that people go through.
- Well, thank you so
much, Simone and Jordan,
I'm liking your posts right now
and I love y'all jamming out to that song.
And that's not all.
Usually, this is the moment
I surprise our guests
with $1,000 from Pilot Pen,
but in the spirit of the show,
Simone and Jordan want
to pay that money forward
to an organization close to their hearts.
So Simone and Jordan, who
are you giving the money to?
- We're going to donate the money to
the Wendy Hilliard Gymnastics Foundation.
They do low cost gymnastics
for over 20,000 youth
in Harlem and Detroit.
And we think that's really good
because gymnastics can be
pretty expensive at times,
so we wanna provide
gymnastics to them as well.
- Yes, I 100% agree.
(audience cheers)
- That's amazing.
So Wendy Hilliard Gymnastics Foundation,
that means our season
long partner, Pilot Pen,
the go to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
will be using their Frixion erasable pen
to write you a check for $1,000.
(audience cheers)
The Gold Over America tour
is in my home state of Texas this weekend.
Houston on Friday
and Fort Worth, where I
was born, on Saturday.
I wish I was there to watch it.
Then 20 more cities after
that. Y'all gotta check it out.
I really do want to check it out.
My kids, they will freak out.
For more info, head to the
Kelly Clarkson Show Instastory.
Thank you so much, ladies,
for sharing your time.
- [Both] Bye, thank you so much.